ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
もうちょっとしたら山活とは確定申告やんマキュアユーチューブの収入ってどうしたら
いいのかな
財務省のページ見てみよう
はい使いものなんだい直接税務署を言ってみよう
こんにちはは確定申告について相談しに来ましたがありがとうございます正しいのは
大変混み合っていましてすでに受け付けを締め切っていますのでまた後日来てください
わかりましたまた来ます今日は確定申告について相談しに来ましたが赤いこちらの
チラシ
8読んでから3階に上がって適切なもと口に入ってください
窓口がたくさんいますので酔わないようにがちーください
迷う ii 頑張ってくださいかかりまして行ってみまーす収入窓口所得金額窓口経費
も渡久地圭さんも洞口
その他へのどぐち
じゃあまず就任も野口行ってみるか
どうなんだろ経費のが先かも
金のほうがいいしかしと7週人のほかて youtube の場合はねにそのと
牛乳
経費
計算
収入いて皆様構図を入れると思いますね
だから収入だから講師の交わしレート
面積全体の面積では学校事務機器の一つにして
耐用年数ではえっ
パソコンの頃に4年間某業出張がにがんやって
1月からの電気代を0.3出かけてティーン様たちが経費もの口ってるから競うぞ無視
してもらい読み替え取ったから3万円を引いちゃ県は別なので1曲日本語の教科書
のちょっこし黄金のスタルチュラをハートのかけらに帰ってパソコンスタンドを引いて
劣化いるピオ0.5でかけて臨んで打った書籍に追加巨人の財布の経費に帰って全部
足すと100万円
んえっ
100万円になります一桁多くないですか ea あっています
国に払ってもらう金額が100万円です家でも構造が60万円ぐらいあったからそれを
既に入っています
間近でもこの中に住民税とか入ってるからあとはないですよねや住民税をまた別には
[音楽]